it going
riley our intern likes to when i say uh
okay riley let's go
he makes it go live and he's like okay
we're live but i caught him because i
was watching the feed he caught him uh
what's up everybody i'm all alone today
i'm all alone here at stream coco beth
has better things to do
so you know what i did i put on my eight
dollar shirt which is real stretchy
that i got uh in new york for eight
dollars and by the way this just goes to
nothing this is skin so boob out we got
a boob pocket today and uh and i came
here and we're gonna play a little game
that uh kind of uh it reflects uh me
being alone today it's called the drift
uh with the one
so i guess it could be adr1ft
uh hey abby abby kirk is crying in the
chat right now why why is that um hey
arson rape
rape
ra r-a-e-p
jungle gym media i said that in a really
bad way so we're off to a great start uh
let's just play shall we this is why i
need somebody else with me because uh
you know i'm a nightmare person uh we
had last week off i hope you all had a
fantastic uh but a little bit depressing
week because there was no conan so i
hope you missed us
hey wmamb tv i will say hi
what's up online
instructor hand for administrator series
4 version 1.6
aerospace north star
mission active date 29 september 2035
well there's my weed floating around
right there on the right
to invert eba control system access
options menu
you know what i got to say something i'm
more into like a female voice does that
make me misogynistic eva look yeah we
don't need this man
we don't need video game tutorials where
you like look around i think it's like
a video game tutorial
where you have to look around is a lot
like when they tell you to put your seat
belt on on a plane
we're there we understand we've been in
a car since 1950 we understand uh
jonathan sanchez we're playing this game
called the drift or adr 1ft they
they tried to make it cool by putting a
activate eba propulsion boost
got it okay here's my weed let's get a
close-up look at my
oh
can i grab my weed can i grab my weed
[Music]
oh jeez
perform eva ascend
yeah i got it i got it man
hey what's up mashallah zara good to see
you
i'll put the overlay on the bottom hey
could you put the overlay on the bottom
thanks pal
perform eva descent
okay got it
you can just tell me all the buttons at
once adrift you know
oh look at this ball let's hit it ooh
header
activate eva propulsion break all right
got it
yep doing it
by the way no one has tied anything down
in the space station everything's just
floating around
performing a mile roll
oh here we go
and let me guess the roll right is this
way is that what you're gonna tell me
next
yup
guys in space no one can hear you scream
also no one can hear you cry which is
why i'm trying to move to space so i
don't keep annoying my neighbors by
weeping all the time
hey what's up justin gomez good to see
you thanks for joining us put my face
cam at the bottom it's been done
activate eba stabilize oh that gets us
back to where we're supposed to be okay
[Music]
three hours later we've finished the
tutorial
oxygen levels are monitored via eva hud
oxygen meter
all right
oh i see okay on the right there
what is this is this a salad our display
via easy it's a space salad
sarmat mr and mr we don't know if it
sucks yet
activate eba environment scan oh the
antelope says i don't think it's
misogynistic it just factors into who
taught you at a young age predominantly
mentally
i had a lot of female stimulation
but i do respect women
that's why uh the patriarchy is a joke
and i know me saying this is gonna light
up
the chat but the patriarchy is a joke
and uh women rule so there there we go
i'm a feminist deal with it
they should have taco bell in space
glenn they should but here's the thing
man you got to be careful about what
taco bell
what space taco bell is going to be on
the menu what taco bell in space what's
going to be on the menu definitely not
crunchy tacos
all that oh that's just gonna float away
you know mostly burritos
uh crunchwrap supremes
am i excited it's baseball season nope i
couldn't care less don't care about
baseball it's just a bunch of people
hitting hitting balls with clubs you
know let's get lit all right joseph you
first
i'm so glad there's a thing now well
thank you ryko britt
all right so where am i supposed to go
is the next question
can we go out into space let's try it
here we go
slowly but surely oh dude we're going
out to space
dope let's do it
oh guys
best thing about space uh you don't need
air conditioning it's so cold you just
crack a window and it gets right down
below freezing before you know it you'll
also die but that's what it is anthony
likes turtles
thank you anthony
i will say the chat never boring you
guys are never boring where's conan well
uh conan's back from japan he was in
japan all last week uh with jordan
apparently if you saw any snapchats or
instagrams we did and uh
so far conan has kicked me four times
today uh i can't he's like blay and he
yelled down the
the office and so our office is really
long and so i walked down there and then
he was just like and started like doing
this
he kind of attacks lately conan has
stopped punching me and he's just moved
into kicks and it's a lot like an emu
attacks you know it's vicious it kind of
comes in
you know the kicks are different because
you don't see him coming because they're
coming up and he's got such long legs
he's mostly leg he's basically like
head
if you you know that uh that that that
song head shoulders knees and toes you
don't need to do the shoulders part it's
just head knees and toes knees and toes
that's all conan that's like conan's
theme song so yeah and you don't i'm not
used to the feet coming up they just
come so quick
plus he grows his toenails out really
long like this and he doesn't wear shoes
in the office so it's kind of like
your talent's coming out i'm just
kidding about that
survivor located initializing ebay yeah
a bunch of kicks today uh and then i
told him about my most recent date
uh and then he said uh get out of my
office and never come back
whoa what's happening
am i really excited oh my god i think
i'm orgasming as an astronaut
oh wait
looks like stuff's messed up oh this
game's kind of like gravity all right
don't let go of that dude
oh geez
what happened to the thing where i was
just flying around all peacefully
also are there
you know i like subtitles guys
where the subtitle says the question
yes
perfect
i had some of that space taco bell
all right
oh okay here's a bottle of oxygen i'll
be i'll drink
perfect
uh cassowary what's a cassowary andrew
castillo
maybe you watched anime and learned some
new kick attacks
i think that's what happened by the way
ah
so everything's aft
what's up miguel
i'd like to play the nintendo switch yes
grand thief i've played it it's dope
i'm having that sandra bullock moment my
life is just a sandra bullock moment
hashtag woke up like this
what am i supposed to do
drinkable oxygen
let go blake go into the light
there's no light in space dude it's all
dark
let me go into
oh my god i'm dying i need more oxygen
who wants to start the death count
i think i'm gonna die here
oh i'm so dead
yep
this isn't good i'm suffocating
where's more that drinkable oxygen all
right we're about to die we're about to
die
we're about to die
we're about to die
that's it that's it we're blacking out
we're blacking out and not like in a
good like drank too much whiskey way
that's it oh come on oh
oh you guys
go into the light you know read by
nature i did go to the light i hope
you're happy
why would i turn around i don't know i
was looking for more drinkable oxygen
oh no liv
oh press the right stick for environment
scan i think you looked away when that
popped up yes that's true okay here we
go
hearty man
it's really close to hungry man which is
the kind of dinner i grew up on
um
so anyway if you just missed it i bought
this shirt for eight dollars i think
it's a knockoff but here's why i bought
it it's a lot of tactile it's very
smooth then this is all we don't know
what's going on here this is like
like a letterman jacket then there's a
bunch of
are these all like olympic years i don't
know what's happening here then america
of course then you get this little skin
underneath ooh there you go peekaboo
our intern loves that little uh just in
case
i i need to like
feel myself up if i'm lonely at the club
you know and no one's near me i can just
yeah this is like my lonely pocket i
call it
uh it's super stretchy and then look on
the back just randomly there's a bunch
of crap what is happening here
what does it say what does it say riley
uh
it's like x1 it's like who knows
and then we got stars and then we got
this
this is like the argentinian flag i
don't know what's happening this shirt's
a mess
this shirt is okay here we go
environment scan
by the way i think it felt bad for me it
gave me more oxygen
oh geez
okay here we go whatever this is
oh i don't want to hit that thing away
i think i want this thing right
don't swat at it like an idiot you're a
rocket scientist dude
well i don't know what that thing is hey
there's a fork
all right here we go here we go we're
going into the uterus area sorry i don't
know umbilical sorry i didn't mean
uterus
i don't know anything about space or
science
so basically it's telling me i'm an
idiot and to stop using the propulsion
so much all right here we go
is there an inside where i can just take
my take my shoes and socks off and kind
of curl up by a fireplace drink a little
rose does that can that happen in this
game
oh no it's chaos
okay
let's do another scan here we go
i'm trying to figure out what this is
why does it keep saying
oh yes oxygen got it boom
hey there's me i got a really big head i
guess it's just my suit
uh
all right where am i going here oh
jesus
does somebody just zap me
okay let's get over it
this game would be sweet in vr by the
way
hey drift guys make this game for vr
it'd be awesome
i should sit up straight i got really
bad posture right now ruin my back
all right fine
i don't know what's happening
i'm not quite sure what's happening with
these things oh here we go got some more
oxygen right here baby
oh yeah
oh fill me up
buttercup
can i strap any of these to my belt
go
all right going into another uterus area
umbilical area you know what i'm talking
about
my favorite color
uh black like my heart i know it's not a
color
vantablack is actually my favorite color
good thing there's all this oxygen
floating around
what am i supposed to do now
whoa here we go
let's get over to the north star baby
it's already on vr assisted art
i have to play this in vr
uh next week on stream coco we have uh
aj
brooks coming in former wwe
person
loud and clear dude
oh god i'm gonna hit the thing i'm gonna
hit the thing oh
oh give me that give me that cash
where's the thing here we go
is this poland spring oxygen because i
only drink pollen spring oxygen here we
go
this game makes me want to do a lot of
like do you guys ever move around is
there a word for that where like you
move around as you're playing a game
like an idiot
oh dr khalif
you know i love smash mouth
sphincter thank you that's the proper
word
i want to look like a douche now that
i'm thin that's true
and i'm succeeding
what about me i don't count
oh let's go over here this is going to
be something
right
here we go we got an o2 station baby
charge me up
right charge me up
hello
let's just do it
does this not work
[ __ ]
somebody once told me don't even get me
started my friend had
that in his wedding by the way that song
and it was fantastic so am i just gonna
sit here by the o2 station never
figuring out how to work it
that is correct all right i guess it
doesn't work let's go
oh there's some oxygen
oh man that's a lot of dandruff
gross that's real gross ah come on
i got it
oh geez oh jeez
where it explodes poop [ __ ]
what's a poop [ __ ] oh come on bearski
you love that song
you love it
it's kind of the scheme is kind of hard
because i guess you kind of have to
choose between moving and breathing
i don't rule thank you phillip for
thinking so
it's red meaning it doesn't work thank
you bada d who in the chat has played
this game because i'm gonna look to you
for some serious help here
um because i am what you uh call stupid
am i going the right way
oh
stay away from those thingies
ah come on oh man
dude
this sucks austin it's not about
dragging anything out it's just about
isn't it fun to constantly constantly
worry about the lack of oxygen and not
being able to enjoy the pretty space yes
that's true you played through this once
how was it
hi from germany hello kya
hello back i was in germany once and i
uh oh no i met a girl named kai in
france but she was from germany which is
very nice
death count too
hey mexico city i'll say hi to mexico
city
love mexico city uh the place to be too
this game is fun i just suck never
mistake
a my clothing choices or b my lack of
ability never confuse that with how a
game actually is
never even heard of this game that's
right crispy meme we like to play games
uh every once in a while we like to play
some fun indie games that people give a
little bit of a larger platform to those
small games because there's so much
noise out there
you know what i'm saying it can't all
it's just you can't all play
blockbusters all the time what's the fun
in that i mean i like a michael bay
movie as much as the next guy but
especially if that next guy is michael
bay himself
i should try dead light what's dead
light
is that like uh dead but less fattening
thank you high five to the
chat look
it's just dad joke of palooza in here i
don't want to hear about it
all right so here we go this way
i think we're going the right way
finland malaysia
i'm about to take a test wish me luck
marwai what's the test
so i want to go this way right
what are the green hey who played this
nile now existencia what's the green
boxes what are those about
this is a hard game marshall and also
i'm terrible so it makes it doubly hard
when you're dumb
i should make giveaways and give away my
shirts i should
it's a good call
feeling rules bazinga
this is dark souls 3
the space dlc
yeah the lord of cinder was in here a
few minutes ago
so what is that what
what's the deal
there we go
oh i see maybe the oxygen came out of
those things
so maybe the maybe the boxes tell me
where the oxygen is coming from
just kidding can't get a handle on how
big i am
oh yeah no [ __ ]
catastrophic really you think so
good there's a lot of stretching
all right so we gotta dodge all this
crap
let's take it slow
because touching this stuff is a really
bad call
take it slow take it slow
okay
uh
[ __ ] is what i like to call totally
[ __ ] is that a space term
i'm space screwed
here we go
i'd like to grab that oxygen please i'd
like to grab the oxygen please
all right let's go
chugging oxygen like five hour energy
that's true
great stretching noises yeah
all right here we go
am i going the right way
don't dab
oxygen
yeah man you keep saying that dude
what am i supposed to do just float out
here like a dick
there's my tooth there's my fork again a
lot of forks on this station
okay
it takes me like all my oxygen to
position myself to get an oxygen thing
which seems kind of stupid
i am reading both i'm reading everything
khali
a little behind on the new voltron how
was the new voltron
i eventually upgraded my screen get more
oxygen and other stuff like boost is
there are there villains in this game or
is the villain uh
my lungs is that like is that like the
villain in this game is the fact i need
to breathe seems unfair
well they got broadband up here that's
dope
stable is a relative term
when you upgrade your boosters
navigation becomes more fun i'm gonna
take your word for it
when does that happen like in like an
hour
maybe i have to open the plant container
just do bong rips is this the right way
or am i going the wrong way here
doesn't look like the right way but i
don't know what is
uh i'm just floating out into
the atmosphere right now which seems
really bad
this can't be right
right i should have gone the other way
the villain is reality as always you're
right andre
uh
so
uh
[Music]
right i should be going the other way
everybody
hey i can see my house from here
this is slow
yeah bong rip shout out always
what um
i'm [ __ ] i think i'm dead
i'm about to die again
because i done done gone the wrong way
i'm playing as sandra bullock yeah but
sandra bullock was way smarter than i am
i'm playing as the guy who got his face
like smashed off two minutes into
gravity
actually maybe this is the sequel to
gravity maybe this is what happens when
clooney floats away spoilers
it can be pretty confusing to navigate
you can look at the circle on your left
oh
all right oh i see okay
the circle oh i see
uh-oh
we're getting close to suffocating oh
this is gonna be bad oh things are going
dark things are going dark
darling sucked down this oxygen uh we're
gonna die here we're gonna die here
we're gonna die here we're gonna die
here we're gonna die here we're gonna
die here we're gonna die here yep
we're dead we're dead we're dead that's
it we're dead we're dead
we're dead that's it oh there's oxygen
yes
oh yes sweet sweet oxygen
so
oh the sphincter no openy
ah
god
i can really go for a space nap right
now that's a nap in space guys tactical
term
so am i supposed to go here
why does my pressurized suit contain
lots of o2 i don't know but here's some
more o2 right here i'm about to suck
down
boom
all right so
this way is the next way it's a window
i don't get
where i'm supposed to go here
everything's messed up all right i came
oh here's another oxygen too
obviously they know that like you have
no idea where you're going here because
they're just giving me tons of
oxygen clooney's fine he has his batman
suit with the sweet bat nips
yeah safely this looks like uh this
definitely looks like a vr game
so i guess this way
ouch
we're gonna go this way i know i went
this way before and we almost died but
we're gonna continue going this way
i'm doing something suck
oh sorry lamissa
so
i'm going towards what i think is the
next
stop right
does this seem like the right way
in space
you can't ask anybody for directions
guys
this doesn't seem right
you know if i would stop panting like an
idiot maybe i wouldn't use up all my
space air
that was called space air
it is probably more about the visual in
vr
i had to sit down take a stress pill and
think things over i'm gonna die here
i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm
dying i'm dead i'm dead
[Music]
hey josh giron
thank you for calling me what i am a
noob
i'm not sure where to go
there must be something inside the
closed sphincter yeah but what
what's behind the sphincter
everybody wants to know
hardiman mankind above all else yeah
right then how about giving us some real
oxygen
man oh man
jarvis
adding to
the dialogue by just saying poop i
appreciate it
you know i always appreciate that
all right
another point of entry yeah t virus
infected i gotta say
uh all the deaths in this are incredibly
uh
jungle gym mania i think the objective
is to
get a fixed
suit i guess
i'm drew no it's just water we're just
drinking water today if you're just
joining us uh we're playing a game
called the drift with a one in it
instead of an eye
i'm wearing a really stretchy weird
shirt that has a pocket
that just opens up to nothing it's just
skin see
it's a good like chest burster shirt
like guys i'm not feeling too
i'm sorry what's wrong with me it's
monday morning everybody
all right let's go
oh you know what it might have just put
me in like a better area
your mind is going a bit brian uh-oh
better go find it
the place i'm in is our digital studio
where we do a lot of our
extras and a lot of shooting
[Music]
come on oh come on
jesus
what a tease ah there we go
whoo all right
you know pure oxygen gets you high guys
so basically we just keep taking bomb
grips in this game i just want everyone
to know that
all right here we go
so i'm guessing on the left
where you can't see
is
are my objectives
actually riley can you move us to like
the top can you move us to the
i guess the top right might be a better
way
so there we go so on the left you can
kind of see there's like arrows and
stuff oh there's some scissors i knocked
into
i don't know uh diego what happened to
our spaceship but it is totally effed
i gotta want it i'm wanting it my dev
water makes you high too i guess
top left siddharth it wasn't the top
left and then people weren't digging it
i feel like we played this part but
maybe i'm crazy
there we go
the name of this game is bong rips in
space
the original name of this game is
bonkers space bomb rips
just getting my ass handed to me by my
own lungs it's pretty depressing
yeah mission control
i'd love to talk to you but
i can either thrust or talk that's what
she said
i missed one there were three there what
did i miss
i don't have to get every oxygen thing
do i
all right we're definitely going the
right way though
see another oxygen thing i'm homing in
on it
all right we're doing well guys here we
go
we're on our way to the next one
you know what this game could use is
like a xenomorph
if i find benjamin if i find a common
trail of oxygen i'm going the right
direction okay cool the problem is when
i get off the right direction it's hard
to get back on it
the game would have been better yeah i
agree it would be fun to find some
puzzles
in this game but maybe that's
okay
i feel like i'm getting better at the
propulsion though right guys come on
right
all right we're back here it's a yeah
it's a floating simulator i thought
i thought astronauts had better cardio
yeah me too
okay
oh this is something
this is something
that's something
dope
what is this
does that do something do i put it in
here
did i do something with this is it like
interstellar can i watch my kids grow up
uh like 30 years in like 10 seconds and
really cry about it
amazing moment by the way
i don't know if you guys have uh seen
the ads for dunkirk nolan's new film but
they film they shot some of that next to
us in stage 16.
and so a bunch of people saw nolan
walking around in a wetsuit which is
really cool
and then i actually saw harry styles
come out of a bathroom dressed in world
war one dressed in world war one outfit
which was like great
it's so weird
we lead a very weird life and there's
all these guys sitting outside the
stage like smoking with all like in
world war one gear
and like all these lifeboats and stuff
it was very cool
very surreal
but apparently nolan likes to use stage
16 uh the stage next to us
and all the stuff said um it had a
different name on it didn't say dunkirk
it's it's something else
all right here we go all right we're
definitely guys are making progress here
i found hal
or how to electric boogaloo
am i supposed to do something with this
do i put the card in somewhere
or do i just keep going
externally damaged
eva repair required
am i doing that in here because it looks
like i should be doing something in here
no but i do see a crazy big thing coming
up
oh see this looks like something cool
oops oops oops whoops
all right here we go
perfect
is there any oxygen in here though is
there any oxygen in here i see some
oxygen here we go
i don't know if i'm getting better is
that are the cracks growing in my
windshield my windshield my space
windshield off
okay i just gotta heal myself
oh here we go there's a little flashing
thing
uh
yeah
what do i do here
uh
can i hit the thing
nope
you're staring at a hot girl is that
what's happening here all right
well that's a bust
hey look my diploma oh here we go okay
put the thing in the thing dude
uh commander oshima i've reviewed your
blah blah blah guarding your alternate
proposal okay yada yada yada
yep stick to your plan close this down
bring it home you okay at the death
samuel good old samuel
director hacking prepared dated
materials my oxygen better not be going
down by the way but i've seen the thor
ragnarok trailer no i have not there's a
pod with green arrows behind me okay
thank you
all right we're done with this i'm tired
of reading this stuff
i'm just going to read a bunch of emails
i'm dying here all right here we go
there's a pod with green arrows behind
me
all right
um
oh here we go over here yeah
oh guys we are gonna
welcome to a new show
it's called pimp my
suit with what's his face who wasn't who
wasn't pimp my ride it was um
oh my god the rapper what's his name
it's like a hardcore rapper
girl i'm looking good
all right great
okay
now my oxygen is
oh it's when i hit stuff it still sucks
oxygen's still going down so this is a
pain in the ass
am i about to see
ben kingsley dead
exhibit that's right exhibit it's so
funny because exhibit is such a hardcore
rapper
and then he's like hey we're gonna make
cool cool looking cars this looks so
funny
what's happening over here
can i take a space nap in here
no
ugh
sebastian thanks for the push called in
a favor to get a transfer approved for
mcdonald today
what am i just like snooping
is this all about like a jealous
ex-boyfriend likes trying to find like
like reading his girl like astronaut
girlfriend's emails
i don't know
look he's speaking french they're
probably doing it
as hard as his home
this is how the this is how the t-virus
got uh
it's not a t-rex virus got to earth
um my ride was so fake they made those
cars last a few weeks tops i mean that's
true of course it's also like those
shows like extreme home makeover like
they're not making
great
quality built homes i think they're just
making uh let's get some more oxygen
spacex dude
i think people must have had sex in
space right haven't they haven't they
tried to do it
don't they have like handles or
something they put on like clothes with
like handles on them
i mean i find kissing girls is hard
enough on earth
of course there's less choices in space
so maybe that favors me
you know
i plea i blew up
not alexistence yeah i blew up the ship
just so i could read people's emails
i do it by the way
right just so i could snoop on my
ex-girlfriend
i love it
don't put it past me
uh you know what i've been watching that
show crazy ex-girlfriend it's awesome
you guys seen it it's really funny
i highly recommend i've also been
listening to that podcast s town
which is fantastic as well it's by the
guys who did cereal it's really good
it's not like cereal but it's awesome
all right we got another one of these
things
how am i going here
this thing doesn't work right the eva
station still doesn't work
still no working all right
gotta find some oxygen and fast
or are we gonna die again here we go
here we go
um i only uh drink like fiji oxygen i'm
sorry
imported from the hills of
yep
i think i want to go this way
luckily somebody left all these glowing
lunch boxes everywhere for me to follow
so my suit's like leaking again bad
i want to meet the engineer who thought
sharing the oxygen i think they have to
do that though right
breathable oxygen breathe the boxing and
propulsion oxygen maybe not
how do they do it in real space we've
had we had uh richard garrott
or garrett on uh stream coco
and he actually went up into space we
should have played this game well i
guess this game wasn't out then
need it
damn it
uh he's been to space he could have told
us what this is like
and how bad i am at playing this game
which is extremely bad
the love of anything turn around and go
the right way i'm going the right way
i mean there's more oxygen so i'm
definitely going the right way
i just think that that's maybe like what
this game is
no
this game is just called space floaties
we don't exactly know what we're
supposed to be doing other other than
snooping on everyone's emails
i wish you could grab
a couple bottles of this oxygen here and
just take it with you
here we go
easy does it it's kind of like operation
in space you know you just gotta
thread the needle whoops i want to go
down
ah
come on dude
not cool
not cool
all right where's the dumb
here we go
you know an interesting thing i learned
about space is a lot of the fuel
why spaceships need so much fuel to get
to skate velocity is not so much
it's eight obviously to get out of the
atmosphere but also to make you go fast
enough that you're sp to get you into
orbit so you're not you need because
you're skimming up and around i never
really realized that
it takes a lot to go up but they're
actually shooting around the earth which
is kind of dope guys i'm really into
space you know
now that i've played this game for five
minutes i'm an expert
tricky life is down for a little uh
space
space sex i don't know man i don't think
it'd be very fun all those fluids
everywhere no thanks
seems like no
thank you gonna pass ooh
those crunchy cheetos because i could i
would love space cheetos although that
would probably be terrible you don't
want cheetos in space because
all the powder goes everywhere
follow the arrow i'm following the arrow
dude oh no wait
is the right way
is this not the right way am i going the
wrong way
oh i am going the wrong way
am i going the wrong way
yeah
i am
really
what arrow
on the left
oh i see oh that arrow oh okay all right
sorry
damn it
damn it
now i'm gonna die cause i wasn't paying
attention
all right here we go
following the arrow i see the arrow guys
i'm on it
she's probably gonna die here in a
second
because i wasn't paying attention to the
arrow but
you know what
maybe there's an extra
pollen spring oxygen over here i've been
going the wrong way not the whole time
come on
the whole time i've been going the wrong
way
for like five minutes
oh jesus christ
ah
there's so many arrows i see right now i
see four different arrows
all right well now i'm going the right
way
you guys got me blabbering about fluids
in space and that's what you get
don't distract me with all this space
fluid talk
for so long says connor oh man oh god
i'm so screwed
getting to space is relatively easy says
ebert you need to be going sideways
really really fast you're busy
continuing falling for the earth and
missing yeah i didn't realize that
because i'm dumb
but i get it
here we go
i see the ice there's so many arrows
they could make there's like three white
arrows they could make one of the arrows
red you know
they wouldn't be hurting themselves by
making an arrow a different color
and by the way here's an idea for games
because this happens a lot if you're
gonna do a tutorial about how to look up
and down how about doing a tutorial
about where the f to go you know
that's a tutorial that i would sit
through like if you get lost here's
where to do it it's not gonna ruin the
game for me
i love like games are like hey if you've
never played a game before here's how to
move around and by the way we're not
going to tell you where to go or what to
do
the stuff you actually need to play the
game no no we're gonna let you figure
out that stuff the stuff that would be
super helpful to be explained by
yourself
all right i am going the right way right
that's the right arrow that i'm looking
at now
i've i've chosen the right
out of 16 different arrows the right
arrow
all right here we go
here we go we're slowly floating out
man you know what this game could use
besides like a xenomorph
um and maybe like maybe some kind of
like lightsaber
i know nasa has a lightsaber come on
guys we all know nasa's been working on
lightsabers
one thing that's actually kind of cool
uh that i love is um
it's kind of cool that like sci-fi
authors i'm a big reader right and
sci-fi authors like well think of
something like in the 50s or something
like you know and then us nerds will
grow up well not us because i'm not
smart but people will grow up and then
like make those things
you know like i don't know the internet
or like a tractor beam like you know
somebody's working on a tractor beam
like i love that i love that people
um
i love that like you know people are
like oh that would be super cool light
sabers existed so
let's try to make a lightsaber
you know elon musk has a lightsaber at
his house we all know that
maybe that's why like coming up these
batteries and tesla and all that stuff
it's just him trying to create a
lightsaber and like okay well i figured
out this new battery technology for my
lightsaber but i guess we'll put it in
cars
am i stoned no i'm just normally like
this i drink a lot of diet coke
so
i think i've changed my brain chemistry
kind of like
oh
kind of like uh john travolta and
phenomenon i'm just trying to like get
super powers by drinking
diet coke
um i saw logan by the way the movie was
dope he's being a super powers
where's clooney we are clooney dude get
with it
no wait something's supposed to happen i
think in here
oh my god i've been going the wrong way
like the entire game
unless i'm following now like
oh different wrong arrow
oh i don't think we've been in here
oh here we go give me the walkman give
me the walkman
[Music]
wait did i need that thing
who's played this game
a clueless gamer mass effect andromeda
would be fun
yeah
escape
dude
launch
all right
well this looks like an important room
so
what's up
so what do we do here exactly
here we go
i'm going to read some more sexy emails
mankind above all else seems a little oh
here we go
all right you don't have to tell me
everything you're doing just do it all
right
so i gotta find all this stuff
my god this dude is no fun why can't
they make like fun robots you know
like cortana at least was like hot
space porn jacob this is the exact
opposite of space porn
unless you find reading manuals erotic
which some people do
reminds me that tom cruise movie what
tom cruise movie
but i go to space in real life after
playing this game yes benjamin
absolutely would i really want to go to
space just working on that 20 million
dollar price tag because we ain't
getting there by smarts you know
so okay
all games eventually boil down to just
like
follow the arrow or you know it's like
it doesn't it kind of doesn't matter
it's just about
it's a remix of different things
all right
here we go out this out the blue door
do i need do i know a game called star
citizen no
there was a game by the way
there was this game i played when i was
a kid where you could choose like eight
different
you could choose like eight different
spaceships and you would like fight with
each other
uh yes the mummy the tom cruise movie
definitely looks like uncharted
system specialist mcdonald
i'm
this guy sounds like what's his name who
played robocop and who's in suicide
squad
joel something mckinnon
broke both of those promises by taking
another selfish
okay no you don't need to swear all
right
profanity's not helping anybody pal also
what am i doing just throwing things
around like
all right
is this the right way
because now guys there's two arrows here
all right
am i supposed to go straight or right or
what
left
i'll take some of that oxygen though
yeah
yeah
i mean this game is aptly named you are
adrift
all right i guess i'm going straight
all right
i'm really knocking into stuff here all
right
you don't need
okay
what do we think we going here
okay
oh
well following oxygen
i could really use some of that oxygen
there's something with the gear on it am
i supposed to like fix that thing give
me that oxygen
am i supposed to fix this thing
uh
there's two things i'm supposed to do
okay
am i supposed to do something with this
don't use the same
things that's like a button
in this you know what i'm saying like
don't put like
the same button that's on my controller
on the thing if it doesn't do anything
guys come on
oh we're going to die we're going to die
up here it's going to be bad
can i make a straight line to the
atmosphere and burn up that's a good
question
i might try it
what is that beeping
yeah i'm kind of surprised this
atmosphere hasn't broke or that the
atmosphere hasn't broken this up either
whoa
oh
hey
you keep asking me that i don't know the
answer to that
i'm supposed to fix it so i can escape
in the space shuttle and start a colony
on mars
how am i going to do that
without somebody else
go towards earth to see if i fall in all
right i'm going to try it let's try it
let's see if i burn up
i'm giving it a shot
here we go
here we go
all right
definitely falling towards earth
by space station i'm moving extremely
slowly towards earth
yeah let's see if i burn up three days
later
i'm still alive
uh
i don't i think you can't
i'm really trying guys
they should make at least one animation
where you burn up what are we doing come
on
benjamin i think the overall objective
is
oh you can't burn up that doesn't seem
fun
oh my god i'm moving so slowly
[Music]
death count four
uh
[Music]
damn it
i wanna be a crispy critter but it's not
to happen that sucks
a bunch of crap
and
just take my helmet off well i wanted to
kind of burn up
[Music]
there's a great uh if you guys like
webcomics there's a great one called the
perry bible fellowship it's like my
favorite web comic
it's all different and it's super dark
and weird and there's one and normally
it's just like three panels and one of
my favorite ones it's called snowflake
and it's basically like
um
it's like there's a it's like this
there's like two astronauts it's like no
gary no he's like ah and he falls and
then he burns up and then the last panel
is just like uh a mom and a child and it
goes like
and they
there's one
snowflake that goes on the kid's tongue
and the mom goes ooh first snowflake of
winter whatever and it's obviously the
astronauts burned up it's hilarious
uh people eating people doesn't get any
funnier
that's right
i can see my house from there that's
right old salty
it's a pg-13 game yeah 2017-2017
pbf rocks yeah you guys perry bible
fellowship's really funny
why are we doing love streaming anytime
again i'm not sure what love streaming
is but i'd love to figure it out
but yes we're gonna we do a lot of live
streaming here we do this every monday
right so where are we going kids
let's follow the magical arrow that i
can't seem to keep following cause i'm
dumb
uh chris goodson i got this shirt for
eight dollars in new york that's got a
pocket that just opens up to skin so
that's fun
there you go that's weird
uh and it's got a bunch of weird numbers
in the back a bunch of random things i i
think this is like a ripoff of a crazy
it's supposed to be a ripoff of like a
like olympic shirt but it's made out of
like weird stretchy stuff and has the
argentinian flag on the side
i don't know what's happening give me
that oxygen
oh yeah
so so far we've been floating around a
lot i mean this game is well named it's
called the drift
yeah we're still in the same game alvin
sorry bro
so maybe we're supposed to go down into
that thing i'm thinking
uh we played some resident evil 7 that
game is real fun and insane in vr very
scary
i kind of almost couldn't even play it
because it was too scary in vr yeah
there we go
how about getting a pc instead of
playing on console well we've played
stuff on pc
confusing shirt agreed
all right
thumbs up
where's conan where's the conan filmed
he is filmed in burbank california right
here on warner brothers
studios
very exciting
uh i saw they also have started filming
powerless that show with danny pewdie
vanessa hudgens right by us
does anybody seem powerless
oh i am
flying now dude we got it we're moving
along at a good clip
i think if i if i dodge the space
garbage
i actually live longer imagine that
oh good one
good one
good one love it
i love crazy robots
my favorite
go inside of the hole get it in
it's a sexy human being i agree white
ops we can't even see ourselves and we
just i think even though the gloved
hands look sexy all right here we go
ah
another day another space sphincter to
get into
a passive computer what
checked out that computer all right
we're going back
you know what the computer is going to
be able to help me with absolutely jack
[ __ ] so get ready
yeah
guess what
guess what smart ass computer don't
computer no worky
look at that it's like somebody dropped
their iphone 9.
now i got to suck up another oxygen
because we had to backtrack
it's just a real spacewalk kind of dario
i feel like this is pretty accurate to
what a spacewalk would be
the heavy breathing heavy breathing is
sexy or maybe she has asthma yeah maybe
she has space asthma
this is working skate for life
andy mutz i don't know if there's an
ichi
i'm wondering if there's any kind of
achievement in this game
it is beautiful though
whoa
here we go
time to get high
[Music]
can i just suck up these bubbles this is
cool
the catch is it's all poison ivy
uh oh guys triangle shaped leaves
don't touch it you're gonna get space
poison ivy
by the way these bubbles are why you
can't have sex in space too many fluids
man it's not good
well nice to see the plants are fine
even though there's
uh philly live this is basically called
this is a drift and there's been some
kind of it's kind of like gravity that
movie gravity in space
so there's been some kind of horrific
disaster and i'm not talking about this
shirt i'm talking about there's been a
horrific disaster in space
and we have to get back to earth somehow
uh the game is basically called float
around and suck up oxygen
uh but it's fun i gotta say i'm having a
good time the graphics are dope
the controls are pretty great
once i get the hang of them
give me that weed
ah vlad conan does play games
um
he plays some games
does this do anything up here
that's just a busted light
blockage detected oh brother
i'm gonna let that one lie
let's see here
all
right
so blockage detected
gotta unblock it
we've eaten too much cheese
and there's a blockage detected okay
what do we have to do here
[Music]
also can i not just open this door
manual clearance required
oh whoa look at this
all of a sudden it's like the fountain
guys i found the tree of life
why is there a giant tree in here
smart idea was that
oh yeah it'd be totally cool man let's
just play like a oak you know
dumb carl always wanting his trees
accelerated growth chamber
all
right
that's cool
i mean this seems like a great use of
space
in a space station but what do i know
do god of war clueless gamer god of war
looks dope the new god of war looks
insane
really cool and a fun take on it too
wouldn't that tree be dead because of no
oxygen yes it would that is correct oh
wait wait wait
guys i got this dope card
get me into the club
uh it's like an extra bottle around here
are there no bottles in here
oh there we go
guys that's just how i do you know i
just pop bottles
bottles and supermodels that's me
mr cool astronaut guy
this gf5 what's that
north missile north mythology is a great
fit too yeah that's true
groot's the pilot
i am groot
all right
back out into space
now this guy again captain whiny captain
i left my kid at home for no reason and
i have to swear a bunch
my god
emo astronaut strikes again
i don't know man you know it's just like
it's just how it is out here you know
what's the piano happening why is there
piano
all right creepy music playing
night is decided by the presence of
sunlight what is the chat i look away
for a minute and the chat gets crazy
sponsor any esports teams no i don't
should i
[Music]
i find an esports team i'd call them
like the
los angeles ointments i think ointment
is an underused word
and if you were going up against a team
called the ointments you'd be like ah
gross
you know get your head uh-oh wait a
second
oh i think i see clooney
[Music]
i think we're about to see mcdonald over
here
[Music]
oh guys it's beautiful look at that los
angeles no that's not los angeles looks
like india down there
oh
there's a concert happening up in space
[Music]
oh i think i just threw something in his
head sorry bro
my bad
mcdonna
well
i think mcdonald's kind of effed
can i do something to him
no sorry madonna
this wasn't very nice
that's it we don't care about mcdonough
more bottles for me
all right bye mcdonald
what's happening in here
am i going the wrong effing way again no
i'm going the right way whoa crazy
that's pretty cool looking the graphics
against gamer dope
wow that's awesome
i am going the wrong way i got to go
back
right i'm following the right arrow
right guys or am i being stupid i found
the stick yeah i found the stick
top gear really
let's see bottle
push this body towards earth viking
funeral
chelsea this game is kind of maddening
i'm not gonna not gonna lie takes
patience
[Music]
so wait it's telling me to
go that way
i don't get it
what am i supposed to do oh this thing
nope
yep keep banging into stuff that's great
okay i get it
does this do anything no am i supposed
to do something with his body oh wait
this thing
here we go
okay let's get that oxygen friend
let's get that oxygen give it to me
let's grab it can we grab it please
we're about to die can we please grab
the oxygen friend
great job
there's a raid on non-precious
commodities is that an eve online joke
all right so i don't understand what i'm
supposed to do here
again why i hate games that are koi all
right i guess we're supposed to go
oh
out
oh here there we go this way i guess
we're supposed to go
did i finish the rest of zero done i
haven't played an estimate
we will play it next week i haven't
actually
signal received
[Applause]
can i put these plants to work for me
all right here we go
o2 leak reduced all right
okay
great
[Music]
you know what i'm gonna do very quick is
just grab this little bottle over here
this little number
this game is a lot of like just reaching
for bottles i think
i guess which was we played witcher 3
and we've done a
really fun
we did a close gamer with witcher 3 it
was awesome
um and actually i think they put i saw
somebody sent to me
one of you amazing people sent um they
put a
witcher 3 easter egg
with conan o'brien
scientist hudson elizabeth
deceased
astronaut lopez teresa
disease
systems specialist
[Music]
yeah baby
you ain't deceasing me
um
was i just talking about i can't
remember
yeah uh
in the game conan there's a
easter egg where you can find
a grave site of
conan o'brian
uh which is kind of dope it's the the
witcher folks who are very nice
i'm put in there
my god how big is the space station
hit the bottle super hard dude
that's all i got
what's beat cop
our earth is capable of greater than
even the death star in terms of numbers
i don't know what that means
am i going to teach conan to play again
anytime soon hopefully
working on a couple
is
things
offline
vocalist mainframe offline
solaris mainframe offline
mobileus mainframe offline
manual mainframe repair required for
service eev operation and launch i don't
know what's happening here due outlets
we did out last already we maybe we
should do number two we did it out last
year it's pretty fun
you can see all that stuff teamcoco.com
cluelessgamer
what game here's a question what game do
you guys want to see us do for the next
coolest gamer
what do you guys think would be great
this looks like an important sphincter i
mean doorway sorry
air versus conan in vr battle
what system is this game for gypsy
danger this game is for the ps4 we're
playing it for as a horror game next
time i do like horror games
i've been playing a lot of i just
started i just beat resident evil 7 and
i've been playing a lot of alien
isolation
lately over my own channel we play on
wednesday
twitch.tv
slash aaron blair
is there music playing now
is that music or is that something
that's gonna is that a buzz saw that's
floating through it's gonna kill me
i don't think i can open this right
oh it opens itself
oh here we go wait something else is
happening
middle gear solid five mass effect
andromeda would be fun
question left to feed up forza forza
with a steering wheel we've done four
isn't it mass effect may be funnier than
terminal
mainframe online
initializing handling switch this gamer
old school mortal kombat
escape for life conan is a noob oh here
we go
oxygen repair detected
initialize bba oxygen repair yes please
oh my god please repair the oxygen va
oxygen capacity 100
exit dva diagnostic nice
oh thank god initializing cerebral core
diagnostic sequence all right so there
we go we got this guys we got the
cerebrum chord
or fabrication required oh we got to
make a new cerebrum
the horror games are good with conan
that's true
oh we're just making a new cerebral core
finally
cerebrum core fabrication complete
so we run module repair check out soma
i've played so much sincerely
the thing about soma is
it was basically just a weird chicken
robot that i was hiding from right it's
just a weird rope chicken robot oh grab
it baby
i got the the drink coaster that i need
to restart the mission
your cerebrum core is in another castle
well played
ah prey looks dope
yeah what games should i be playing
i have so much more oxygen you guys
oh wait am i going the wrong way again
answer is yes
i want to go
oh out this way
there we go
[Music]
what's better for entertaining streams
good games or bad games i don't know it
kind of depends i think the only games
that are bad for streams are boring
games
uh good games or bad games can also be
good uh not sure dan don't know what the
next one is very soon though
i'm waiting on a couple things
there's a vr dating simulation
what is that i need to know about that
immediately
[Music]
why are there no bodies floating around
we've seen one body
i mean i think that the space station is
just really big and there's not a lot of
uh
encrypted internal data transmission
received uh-oh
sender
more ex-girlfriend emails part of an
aerospace mission director
6 june 2037
tetris stream
the settlement date for hardiman colony
luna 2 is upon us
our projections and data indicate that
well hand forces let him in on the fun
system seriously if you are dating
somebody
there's vr pornography no thanks i don't
want i didn't that's too real man
nothing's creative in the face of
failure but now it's not the time for
disruption here we go it's imperative
that you follow protocol look at this
dude in order to meet our goals ensure
the success of the mission
look at this
oh my god
it's a dope oxygen bomb finally
all right which way am i going here
i haven't saw i haven't actually died in
a while
[Music]
it's banned
my psn is just blared it's my last name
impossible to spell
b l e y a e r t
oh yeah
guys i am popping bottles right and left
oh you know what actually
i hate to say this there's no good time
to end this game because it's all kind
of whatever but
i think that's it for today's stream i
think that's gonna do it
um i know floating around has been um
time flies when you're floating around
uh and just sucking down oxygen bottles
but
that's gonna do it for today uh make
sure to tune in right back here next
monday pacific noon for aj brooks who's
going to be our guest from the wwe she's
also the wife of cm punk which is pretty
great she'll be joining us to talk about
our new book
and
uh again follow me on twitch twitch.tv
aaron blair i'll be streaming on
wednesday night and again on sunday
night playing alien isolation trying to
beat that game uh and yeah hit us up on
twitter and make sure to follow us on
facebook
and watch the show tonight who's on the
show tonight
jenna elfman
oh dave keckner who's the best
and ian abramson there you go uh make
sure to tune in tonight 11 10 central on
tbs um that's it i can't do any more
floating around guys i just can't do it
i'm sorry uh i'm gonna go huff some real
oxygen uh back uh in the office and
always remember
never forget
the boob pocket we'll see you guys uh
next monday right back at noon on stream
coco see you later bye
you